so guys we have been given a trailer
update for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness there's going to
be potential spoilers for spider-man no
way home and doctor strange 2. without
the way let's get into it now there was
a rumor that apparently we're going to
get the trailer for doctor strange 2 at
the end of this year then another rumor
came out that we actually get in the
trailer for this movie as the second
post-credits scene of spider-man no way
home now i think it's entirely possible
that this rumor is actually true because
at the end of captain america one they
actually showed the trailer for the
first avengers as a post-credits scene
if this rumor is true it means um the
trailer will not be publicly released
for a little bit no one knows when it
will be publicly released but i would
say a couple weeks maybe i guess we'll
just have to wait and see to see if this
rumor is actually correct but anyway we
actually do have some details on what
this trailer will contain again take
this with a grain of salt as it's a
rumor so this trailer description might
not be true but i'm going to cover it
for you guys anyway as there is some
credit to it so the trailer opens with
doctor strange closing the rift from the
end of no way home gargantos is shown as
a voiceover of doctor strange describing
the cosmic horror which feeds in the
fractures of time america chavez or miss
america jokingly asks isn't that hp
lovecraft and doctor strange replies i'm
not a fan one that can be seen floating
above some buildings in a mirror
dimension as she is absorbing energy
from everyone in the city we then have
short shots of magical action and doctor
strange telling chavez infinite
possibility means infinite threats the
trailer ends with guy gantos launching a
boss at strange a voice off screen says
this was not on my list of things to do
in new york now i believe there was
actually a toy league of doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness which
showed gargantus and miss america now
that's about it for this video it seems
in doctor strange and multiverse of
madness we'll be getting a lot of
characters introduced into the mcu which
is pretty exciting so i'm really excited
to see this film but anyway what do you
guys think do you think this rumor is
true and what do you think of the rumor
does it sound like a good trailer let me
know in the comment section below and
also don't forget to like and subscribe
and to turn notifications on to show
your support thanks for watching guys